I see the horror of like people with
their cell phones recording their mother
screaming as she's being pulled out of
her living room and then like every day
that kind of stuff on social media
getting played on NBC and like now
imagine this now imagine a video of a
woman crying and screaming as she's
being pulled from a bank vault carrying
a bunch of cash yeah we we we don't we
don't look at that crime being committed
and go oh that poor woman or the seventh
time Deport a guy that raped women with
Reckless abandon or or you drove drunk
for the fifth time in the United States
and killed someone's son or smugg fentel
across the border time and time again
killing hundreds of thousands of
Americans like you know there's a video
of a man being arrested in the subway
and the cops are roughing him up you
know not not really F hitting or
anything but they're like grabbing his
arm they're pulling it he's resisting
and there's all these comments on
Twitter they're like why is he doing why
are the cops doing this this man he
didn't even do anything he was fighting
cops yeah he he he jumped the turn they
said stop we're going to give you a
ticket he fought with the cops they
fought back and arrested him yes that's
how you enforce laws that's victim crime